si es algunos minutos comenzó la sesión
en el pleno del parlamento el día de hoy
deberá asistir el presidente de la
república para defenderse de las
acusaciones en su contra por el supuesto
delito de peculado qué es lo que va a
pasar aquí en la asamblea nacional al
principio los asambleístas interpelantes
como acusadores intervendrán en
principio interpretará La asambleísta
Viviana que será la principal
interpelante en contra del presidente de
la república ya se va a demorar
aproximadamente una hora posteriormente
también va a intervenir el asambleísta
Esteban Torres Quien será el segundo
interpelante en contra del presidente de
la república pero en medio de este
desarrollo de la asamblea nacional
sucede un hecho histórico por primera
vez asiste a una asamblea nacional el
presidente democráticamente electo y
para ser enjuiciado por el presunto
delito de peculado de medida de un
juicio político todo esto se
desarrollará en dos horas y
posteriormente el presidente de la
república asistirá al pleno del
parlamento para responder así a los
alegatos y estas acusaciones en su
contra posteriormente también
habrá una defensa por parte de los
asambleístas por el cual se desarrollará
al menos de siete horas antes de abrir
el debate Qué puede suceder bueno es la
gran pregunta sobre todo el negocio de
los votos en el parlamento son los que
decidirán el destino del presidente de
la república